in startups there always seems to be a
tension between two paths distribution
give it for free and capture a big chunk
of the market or earnings also known as
making money charge for your work but
then you limit the distribution to only
paying customers however if you think on
your business plan in advance there are
many cases where you could do both from
the beginning a great strategy will be
to use the freemium model you allow your
users to use the service for free and
then convert the power users to a paying
customers take for example a company
that does it very well wuff ooh the free
version lets you try the product and see
the value in it they show you the
benefits right there on the first step
of the registration they focus on the
most important benefits if you need to
become a heavy users in their case more
than 100 replied per month they ask for
a payment but at this point you as the
user understand the work they did for
you and it's available and worth the
price